so this is the dask tutorial um I will
give you a quick intro to what dask is
and how you can use
it is here anyone who is familiar with
what D is has already used it or
okay um are people here fam with like
ERS I can
learn um TK integrates with all of these
libr um we will today look at how like
you can scale a c Tas and also how you
can run aary python code in parallel to
um D either on a local machine or on a
distributed
system so a little bit about me um I
work at coil where we deploy D for
people in the
cloud um I have a background in
mathematics um I work with the open
source I worked in the open source base
for quite some time now I'm a pandas
maintainer for like close to four years
now and since I work on at coil I'm also
a d my main focus is making D data PRS
faster at the moment um this is
something I'll talk about Friday
you're um what we will look at today I
give a quick intro like 10 to 15 minutes
what the ask is um then we will work on
dusk clusters um in the beginning we
will work on a local cluster that only
runs on a single machine and then we
will scale out to a distributed cluster
that runs in the cloud and do some heavy
data frame
processing and we'll have a Q&A in the
end but really if you have any questions
just raise your hand and I try to answer
them on the spot um we don't have to
wait till the end if you have anything
that you want to know more
about we will do some exercises later on
um but but we'll get to how we can set
this up um in a little
bit um anyone here that has an idea why
he wants to learn more about askk do you
have like workflows that does that will
benefit from ask or basically anything
just want to learn a new
to learning how to parize faster like
sit around waiting I think be
more
it's perfect that's
what um anyone familiar with one of
these three things your code is too
slow um your data doesn't fit into
memory that's another
common um or maybe
both um that's a nice diagram where task
is useful like if you're in the bottom
left corner you have an acceptable
runtime and your stuff fits into memory
then you should bother with D um but it
it either takes too long or you have
memory errors or both of them then dusk
is very helpful uh or can be very
helpful depends on the use case a little
bit um we will today focus on like the
upper left and the down right and then
combine both of them together like if
your workflow is for example pandas on
based and it runs in like a second or a
half a second then don't bother with
that that's not where Das is useful
there's too much overhead in a
distributed way that this would be
beneficial to users but if your workflo
runs for hours or your data frame arrays
don't fited to memory then D is a tool
that can help
you so what is that um D brings the
power of parallel Computing to the Pata
ecosystem um historically D was built
around numai and
panis um dusk itself was founded like
almost 10 years ago now um initially the
first API is by dask array which
parallelizes nump calculations and D
data frame which is the same but for
pandas but pretty quickly like how users
were building their own weird ways of
like misusing
the public API so what we did what was
done back then is um was a new a do
provided a new API that allowed for
lower level parallels
um generally the goal is like do more
work in less
time um that's what parales this
for generally like python is a very
powerful language especially through all
the third party
Integrations um third party libraries
like I can learn P tendo
flow um but all of them most of them
don't scale very well naturally um they
were implemented for single machine
usage um lots of people use Python but
if you reach the boundary of a single
machine then you need other tools than
what you would normally do and that's
where D or also something like spark
normally comes
in um the D data frame API for example
reps the pandas
API and most of the things that you
would do in panders are very similar at
TK obviously it's not a one toone switch
because distributed computing is very
different from Computing on a single
note but at least the apis will feel
familiar from all the Integrations the
DK
build before we get going with our
notebooks we will we will look a bit
more deeply into how DK scales pens just
to give you an idea how the distributed
model in
works
I might be a bit biased as I said I'm a
penas maintainer but penis is great if
you work on small and mediumsized data
sets like as soon as your data sets grow
then the single core functionality of
pandas will reach its limits at some
point like if you have a data set that
has 10 GB of paret files and pandas is
probably not the right tool at the
moment because you would ideally like
to process this on more than one um core
on your machine
most notebooks today have at least four
eight 12 cores so only using one is not
the most efficient thank
you that's where dusk comes in um it's
basically the same car but we plug in a
different engine
um the API is very very similar we will
see this later like most of the things
that you can do in pan are very very
similar and D um but we looks the limit
on data size and on processing power um
dusk really can run on huge single
machines and utilize all the cores but
it can also scale out to hundreds of
machines in the
cloud there's not really a limit on data
size
anymore that's
do as I said what pandas does is it uses
One Core and dusk comes in and uses all
your
course and it triggers Panda's
computations on each and each and single
each and every one of the course that
are
available if you want to scale on then
dask just does the same but remov of the
machines um dask is aware of all the
workers in your system and it pctures
pictures the pandas computations onto
all of the
machines Adas data frame by nature is
like a collection of pandas data frames
if you have a d data frame with 100 GB
of memory chances are that you have like
between 500 and 1,000 small data
frames D just orchestrates um all these
panas data frames and brings the
computations together um we don't
Implement new stuff in dusk except for a
small subset of the API that's different
in a distributed base
but if he would use a sum then what dusk
does it computes a sum on every one of
the penis data frames then it squashes
the results together and sums them up
again so there's no custom
implementation for us we dispatch for
most of the things to hand us and just
handle the
orchestration things like merging work
different in a distributed system
because if you merge two data frames
like the value on the left might be on
machine one and the corresponding value
on the right might be on machine 50 so
we have to put pull it push the data
through the network to get them to the
same machine so that's these are areas
where we Implement custom
stuff so what we'll do now
um we need a notebook um to run the
materials for the tutorial um we will
use coil for this um
historically coiled um spins up D
clusters but we can also use it to
create a notebook with a Docker image
that has all the materials available so
we don't have to install anything for
this Lo the only thing that you have to
do is um P install coil in any python
environment you can also do cona or M
install um doesn't really matter it's a
python only Library so there are no um
there's no compiled stuff in
there and then we come to the next two
steps
um would be great if you could run
through that real quick um and then we
continue any questions just raise your
hand
pref version ofy sorry pref version of
py anything above 3.8 is fine doesn't
matter and the co log in and the co
notebook star is something we up to
later you don't have to type
that just inst installing and then we'll
jump over to the GitHub repository you
copy paste the remaining
set
does anyone need a little bit more
time
so everyone is finished with installing
coil you can move over to this link um
task minus NYC um and that's a GitHub
repository and scroll down to the read
me um
[Music]
file
so what we're doing now is we're logging
into coil um I pregenerated a token um
under my account so you will all log in
as me um and then we can use that to
spin up resources that we can use for
the um dask
exploration um you can just copy paste
um the statement into the terminal where
you installed um coil and then it should
take a couple of seconds and then there
is a screen of authentication
successful should look something like
this
[Music]
naan David will help you if you run into
any
problem
TR
[Music]
and when you copy paste this command can
you
add minus- Das Das
account and then
tutorial
[Music]
that's
doesn't
[Music]
sorry only the part in the second line
here is what you have to add does this
work it's a good okay then this will
take like between one and 2 minutes
until the
instance
okay um when you see that the notebook
is starting up that's what the witch is
telling you um then it will take between
1 and 2 minutes and then there will open
a tab in your default browser um to
bring you to the um to the
[Music]
to let
me
so if you're getting a network error
we're looking into it right now we'll
get that I think they figured out over
here okay uh on the uh on the uh there
is no
[Music]
account so if you're copy you have to
add that
account yeah that work for me after
internal thank I just
have
just
sh
sorry
I but
let have you
installed um no okay interesting
try
did
got did you all get to the
um
showing
the
um my notebook's booting now um there's
a folder that's called
notebooks and then there is z
test that notebook and just run through
the cells um if you go from top to
bottom then they should all work very
well I give you like 2 or 3 minutes for
that before we before I run through them
and explain you what happens there just
that you can get a little bit of a feel
for how dusk
works this your um
notebook
termin
sec
this
original what
it
this is exactly
[Music]
has
yeah
[Music]
um so you should all have this tab
that's showing the notbook um the
tutorial materials are all in
there and now we'll just go like briefly
through through the test drive notebook
that is a very very brief intro to dask
On a local machine um before we move
over to like scaling a bit more
aggressively so we will start with dask
data
frames generally dusk has like many many
extensions there's dusk array dask data
frame a couple of other things um by
convention we import this as DD like
someone decided that all of our data
science libraries are to
import
um and then we prep um we download the
files real quick um The Notebook is spin
up in the cloud so network connection is
fine um these are a couple of gigabytes
um if you would load this with pandas we
would get out of memory errors um that's
why we move to dusk
here
and what we can see here is um instead
of pd. read CSV we just do a DD for D
data frame that read CSV um command is
very similar and we specify couple of
our types and now we dusk actually
didn't actually do anything dusk is lazy
so it's just registered our intent to
read this csb file and now we can do a
head to get some data
um up until now this was exactly the
same API that we would have used for
pandas um the statements are
syntactically exactly the
same um
since dask is lazy we have to tell dask
at some point that we want to trigger
computation we will go that into we'll
go into more detail later on um head is
just an except but if we want to do a
group ey here
then we use Panda syntax up until the
mean sorry for that and then we tell Das
with compute that now we want to see um
what's going on
here and this will take a little bit as
I said it's a couple of gigabytes if you
would have done this with pis this would
have run for um 30 to 40 seconds on a
bigger machine the Tas uses all of our
course and so it's relatively
quick um we briefly look at like our
data frame um if you would do this in
panas then you would get the data askk
is just telling you that you have these
columns these columns have these dat
data types but dusk actually doesn't
know yet which data are in these columns
it just knows how they will look later
on this is what dusk registers like we
call this the task graph it's the
execution plan that um we will execute
later on like we start with a read CSV
then we will convert to P string this is
internal detail and then we will get our
result back um we have like nine
different CSV files that's why you have
nine different um execution execution
strings
here
um dusk array is a n extension um DK
data frame wraps the Panda's API pretty
closely um the differen is for arrays
are even smaller than they are for data
frames because arrays scale a little bit
better over machines than data frames
do so we create a Rand random array
um and what we have to what we can tell
dask is that we want each of our um
numpy arrays inside of our huge um dusk
array to have like thow 1,000 rows and
1,000 columns um and this is is what we
end up getting we can also like modify
this and tell it like we want 2,000
row then this will look a little bit
different they are not squares anymore
um they are a bit longer than they are
wide
now we call this chunks like one chunk
is one ire
R and then we can get back to our um
syntax um n syntax like we
select 10 rows and five Colum
and again nothing happened here we have
to trigger an explicit compute to get
any get any results but as soon as we do
this we get back a npire array that we
can do nire calculations on um compute
moves from the DK array that is lazy
back to the non non P that is
eager as you can see we had a pretty
huge array but dusk was able to sum this
up relatively
quickly um in the interest of time I
will skip the delay part we will look
into futures um in a little bit that
which is a very similar
API
true um in here
or
okay you did DF
shap like this is lazy it doesn't
actually trigger any computation if you
want to like get a result here then you
would have to do compute um yes which
then will like dusk doesn't know how
long your data frame is it knows how
many columns you have but it doesn't
know the length and the length requires
a computation so if you would do like LF
it we'll get back the number of rows but
this is actually a little bit more
expensive because it has to look at the
data and read them from disk and then
store them in in memory on your machine
and then compute the length for every
one of the
CHS any other questions so
far before we look into some more like
Hands-On results I give a brief overview
of how dask works from an infrastructure
point of
view if you tell dask that you want to
compute anything on your array data
frame or any other dask
structure then just creates a collection
which is a DK data frame a DK scaler a
DK
series before we execute this we have to
create a task graph which is an
execution plan basically it tells it
creates the order in which you have to
execute which to have in which dask has
to execute all your operations for
example if you read from Storage then do
a group ey and then a sum um the task
graph will encode this knowledge that
you first have to read storage before
you can do your group ey and then you
can calculate your sum um it wouldn't
work the other run that's what the task
graph
is now can run in many different
environments like you can tip install
dask on your local machine and run it
there on without doing any specific
setup but the more common usage is that
we use a distributed scheduler that
schedules these tasks on many many many
different
machines for example a 20 worker cluster
in the cloud something we spin up little
bit
later um the distributed schedule here
is the one that's firstly the most
complicated umul but it's also the
umul that is the most optimized because
that's the more common use case and
running it on a single machine is
relatively simple compared to executing
it in a distributed
environment so quick terminology um a
dask client that's normally your laptop
or wherever you run dask from um in this
tutorial will be the notebook um then
there's the schedul that's actually
running on your cluster um it's not
running on your notebook so there's
network communication between the client
schum and a schul again is aware of how
many workers your cluster has if your
cluster has 100 workers they are all
registered at the schul um schul and
workers normally run in the same like
Network so they will both run at AWS or
at one of your local data centers and
the client connects to
them
if you look like this at this is if you
look at building a barn this is a bit
similar like you have a lot of workers
that do the actual
work um like building the walls the roof
whatever and then you have the DK
scheduler which keeps all of the control
like he tells the workers to do this
task and then the other workers to do
something
else our graph is more or less like our
plan how we want to execute all things
this is what the schedular uses as a
baseline to make
decisions and then there are a bunch of
python libraries that integrate with
dusk um that do the actual like
computations the heavy
lifting this brings back like when to
use D brings back our diagram from the
beginning if you have acceptable runtime
then you don't have to worry about dask
but if you run into like either
performance issues or memory issues then
you can switch over to dusk and give it
a shot to speed up your
stuff what we generally suggest users is
that they shouldn't use dask if you if
they don't have to like distributed
computing brings in a lot of heavy stuff
and if your computations run fine on a
single Noe then you shouldn't have to
worry about this um this is a bit
similar to like spark usage for example
if you have a small tiny kind of data
frame you wouldn't move to spark because
setup is like a pain and you don't want
to deal with
that and the notebook also contains a
couple of links to DK documentation and
block posts that give a deeper insight
into these Concepts and how you can get
started let's now move over to the um
the Futures notebook which is the second
one
O2
and when you're there you can execute
the first cell we will need that later
for some
exercises
um this cell will spin up a local D
cluster that is only running on this
machine so there's no network
communication the client on and the
cluster are in the same like
instance this is helpful if you want to
parallelize some things but your
resources generally on this machine are
sufficient for example if you have a
huge machine somewhere in the basement
that has a terabyte of ram you might not
want to switch over to the cloud because
that just brings additional complexity
like if your data fits in there you can
use a local cluster that runs only in
this
machine DP comes with a dashboard that
shows you what's going on on your
cluster this is on the left here the
dask logo um
if you open up this tab and press search
icon then it will connect you to your
task
cluster these are all the different like
diagnostic tools that provide um
generally in the beginning it makes
sense to look at the task stream which
is like in the bottom
for and we can open that one up and the
progress which is a bit above that this
is also something that's interesting to
look
at when you found these two we can just
arrang them on the right of our notebook
so that we can still see our
code I'm just by pulling them
over
we will now look into dusk futures um D
Futures are built on uh are designed
like the futures um library from the
python stand Library the API is more or
less the same but they are a bit like
multiprocessing on steroid so you can
either scale them on your local machine
or you can scale them out distributed in
Cloud um and thus candles all the
orchestration for you and a typical
workflow that we see is that users
process a bunch of files and want to do
this in parallel every file like does a
transformation and then you write the
results somewhere like on a database s
fre um local storage something like that
this is where Futures are very helpful
if your computation is unstructured and
it doesn't fit like into the data frame
um world or into the array world or into
any other libraries then you just and
you just want to write PL python
code this is where Futures are helpful
um what we do is we have like three very
trivial functions increment decrement
and ad
um we could run all of these three like
sequentially without using BK at all but
we added a random sleep so that it takes
a bit longer and we can see
more so the computation works perfectly
fine but we can also submit it to our TK
cluster and then we see something
happening over
here
um we told D that we want to do one
computation um this was registered on
the schu and a schu then distributes
this to our workers um the future itself
like client. submit tells the scheduler
that we want to execute this but it
doesn't block on the computation so if
your computation would run for hours the
python session would still return
immediately back to you and the future
status is pening so it's like schedule
on it's like on a schedu and we get
scheduled soon since this is a like very
short computation um if we look at the
future again then we will get status
finished that means that our computation
is like
done and future result can we can use
future result to look at um whatever we
computed
there
um we can also submit like multiple um
things at once um like client. submit
can be used on any random function we
now submit two increments and then we
sum them up and then we can we will be
able to see on the right how um these
will get
executed so we have two like increments
up here and then the sum which is down
here um so dusk took care of that for us
um of the scheduling for
us and returned whatever we computed um
back to our
machine now we have a quick exercise
um the previous functions that we had
like increment and decrement we can do
this in a loop
sequentially and like basically 10 times
but this will take a little bit because
every one of these calls sleeps and so
we will roughly spend 10 seconds in that
Loop
um like 9.3 seconds um this is a
workflow that can like get parallelized
pretty easily so there's no need that we
have to do this sequentially because the
results don't depend on each other um
between the different iterations so we
can use Dusk to
um to parallelize to work
um so what you can do is like basically
copy this code statement and then use
cent. submit um analogous to what we did
up here
um to distribute at to register this
work on the schedule um I would give you
like two minutes to play around a little
bit and then we can go through this
together
for
so the changes we have to make to our
follow are pretty small um we add a
client. submit to both lines and then we
tell Das we want to use the function
increment and hand over the argument
X
we can do the same thing
for for decr and the decrement function
and we want to hand over the previous
result of the first interation um dusk
will figure this out automatically for
you that the second line depends on the
first line for every
Loop and then we can like run all of
this
um if you want the results back you can
do client
together and put in all the Futures that
we
created yep thank
you then we can see how dask utilizes
all of our course um like I gave him
eight different workers and we executed
stuff on all of them obviously like 10
iterations aren't that many if we scale
this out to 100 and we will be able to
see a little bit better what's going on
here um D just uses all of its workers
and schedules the computations um
sequentially on every one of these cores
that means if you would have like 50
workers we could do this way faster than
we can do it with like eight so this
would scale out pretty linearly to um a
bigger
machine can also do 500 you can increase
this as much as we want
um generally this is a helpful API if
you want to do anything in Python that
doesn't fit into any libraries um if you
can do something easily with a data
frame then you shouldn't bother with um
any of the lowlevel stuff because that
just cause more work
um this will run a little bit but we
will move over to the data frame
notebook um this is number
three
um before I
yes um I we booted them on um a machines
before course so I just said I want
eight them so that's it a little bit
better um by default DK will create one
worker per core um if you do a local
cluster so you would have gotten four
workers but that was a little bit too
low for
them if you do like serious processing
not increment decrement then that's too
much like it would lead to over
subscription on your um resources and
slow you down um normally the default is
pretty
sensible before we get started with the
um with the D data frame stuff I would
like to ask you to execute this line
here that will spin over a cluster at
AWS but this will take around 2 minutes
so um we can uh go over the theory while
we
waiting
um just execute that cell and then it
will do its
thing um as we like briefly looked at
earlier um D data frame is basically
parallelized pandas pandas is a single
core D is multicore and also multiple
machines so we can process like a lot
more data then and scan in efficient
time on the other side um it's not I
wouldn't recommend using dask if your
data frame has only has a couple million
rows then pandas should be totally
fine you would move to dusk when pandas
isn't sufficient anymore like it's too
slow too much memory
whatever um West mckin he's the pandas
founder once said like you should have 5
to 10 times as much RAM as the size of
your data set um if you use pandas
that's not totally true any anymore like
we did a lot of memory optimizations
that reduced the memory footprint of
panas since 2.0 but still if you have
don't have like three times as much
memory as you have um data then you will
still run into problems um five is
probably a sensible default at this
point um my cluster now has arrived um
so if you move over to the dusk um logo
left again and refresh your dask um dusk
cluster then we will connect to the
distributed cluster that is in the
cloud I just press the um search icon
and then it will refresh all the
dashboards that you might have opened
earlier we will look at the New York
City Uber and lift rights data set um
that's a data set that tracks all the
Uber and lift um right shares um that
happen in New York City um it has around
100 GB in memory so that wouldn't be a
sensible pandas wouldn't be a sensible
solution for that
problem um we but D can handle this
easily this is on the smaller size of
data sets that you can process with
dusk um I forgot to import dusk data
frame as I said ear by convention we use
DD
um you can use basically any um short
form but this is what all the
documentation and St overflow and
whatever
uses
um
yes yes I just had a quick question
regarding D for data frame uh could you
throw some light on like what's the
difference between d data frame and
Apache spark or map use like for data
manipulation um
spark is very very good at map use um if
your Paradigm fits in there then spark
is probably a sensible Choice um because
does a lot of py planning um we are
building this into DK now so and then we
will get up to speed there but if you
need more flexibility then like dusk is
a better choice um dusk uses most of the
Candace API so if there there are things
that you can do in Candace that you
can't do in Spar like there are lots of
things then dusk is probably a better um
choice for that that's that answer your
question but if you just do group by and
then a su then spark is very good at
that this
depends coil handles this for if if you
use a managed service um but if you do
this yourself for example with
kubernetes then you would have to
install all the same py environment on
allio workers um so this is not handled
by dask out the box um dask relies on
having the same environment on schedular
worker and on your local machine
um I've been using arrow on my machine
very bigger machine so I don't do
distribute is there still motivated to
move or I what works now it's fine but
why would I pick this so you're using
Arrow only without any Library St build
on top of arrows
correct it's alline I can of build my
quer and
ex I'm moving that
from um not not every part of Arrow is
in Python not every part of Arrow is
multi um so if you do a sum over a huge
array this will still be single thre um
while dusk would split this up in chunks
and then do these chunks in parallel but
if your workflow works fine with arrow
because the movie threading is available
what for whatever you do then stick with
arrow personally I don't
too strict for me like pandas is an
arrow backend these days and
we pitch over a lot of these problems
for users but like this is
personal and now we have our data frame
um these are paret files they are stored
in S3 so we have to download them to our
cluster um like network speed in the
cloud is pretty fast but it's still not
an instant
operation um so we start with Computing
the length of our data
prame and now we will see on the right
side that um we have 720 different
parket files and dusk is like reading
all of them and Computing the
length um it's like I don't
know 783 billion rows million rows sorry
um this would have taken forever if you
use something that's only single note
but D was able to do this like in a
couple of
seconds um we can also look a little bit
at our data and compute the head the
head looks only at the first file
because we know that um the first like n
rows are in there so this is pretty fast
we don't have to look at all of them and
then we get back a p data frame that
contains the first five rows of our data
set um this is generally helpful if you
want to have an idea what's in your data
set but not to do any actual
computations
obviously
um D grabs the pandas API pretty closely
so if you want to compute the max of the
driver pay like this is the amount that
is paid to your Uber driver from Uber
itself not the amount that your um ride
cost then we can use exactly the panis
API and trigger a compute in the
end this again reads the data sent from
S3 and then computes the max so the
maximum fair was like around $5,000 I
don't know where this person me but must
have been a long R
um since DK is lazy it won't cash
intermediate results which can be a bit
annoying if you repeatedly want to
access the same data source um there's a
thing that's called persist that will
load your data into
memory
and then all these data will be
available on your cluster so you don't
have to repeatedly access S3 which means
that computations afterwards will be
veryable since there's no IO stuff no
network
stuff um you already have all your
pandas data frames into
memory in
memory um so if you do something like
length now the L
now this is very very fast there's no
like S free stuff anymore it's just like
it asks all the 720 penis data frames
what their length was and then
Aggregates the results together
um DDF do columns is exactly the same as
um at DF do columns of pend data frame
it shows you the index of your columns
which is helpful if you want to do
aggregations and stuff like that or just
want to see how your um how you example
looks like and now I have a couple of
short exercises I would give you five
minutes for that just to play a little
bit around with the cluster um it's all
of these um curies have the panda syntax
and then a do compute at the end um it's
pretty closely aligned with the pandas
API
for
um for folks who got a permission error
would you try adding this line to the
rep par
C
take that bigger
Patrick take that bigger yeah thank
you
sorry I have a question so you mentioned
about a function
procs in memory uh so if we don't do
that then are all the operations
happening over the
network if you don't do that then if you
compute a sum over one column it will
reach from S3 and then do the sum
computation if your next cell is doing a
minimum computation on the same column
it will again read from S3 and then do
the minimum computation will it be slow
in that case if your data set is large
yes uh
so then if we bring all the data in
memory will that not cause a memory
issue and the data is scattered over
your cluster so if each of your machines
has like 16 gab and you have 20 of them
then you have 320 GB of memory available
the data set only has like 100 GB so
dask will distribute the 100 gab evenly
across your workers and then every
worker will have like 5 GB of memory we
can look at this
here
like each and every one of these workers
holds around 5 gab and since every
worker 16 GB we have fine um this would
obviously be problematic if your data
set is like 1 Tab and you have like 300
GB of memory available then this option
is not possible um then you would have
to read from a rep but workers are
already over the
[Music]
network yes but if you do like on the
data frame a s computation then every
worker will have one row to send over
the network and that's like a couple of
kiloby that's pretty cheap so Bas is
basically Distributing the work Loop yes
okay
for
I will go briefly through the first
couple of um examples before we wrap up
our questions we only have like six
minutes
left um how many roads are in our data
set is the same as we've seen before
like it's just a length
computation um this is a bit more
interesting um there's a color tips
which um represents the amount that was
given as a tip for every writer and we
can find out um how many rides were
tipped in total
um we use the panda syntax here we
select the
column um tips and filter for tips being
greater than
zero I have a
here and then we can do
a length computation on that
one um like 124 million so that's
roughly that's not that much I would
have expected
more
um
we can also find out like with a group I
how many right rights are operated by
one single
operator um this again is like Panda
syntax and then we use this column which
spe specifies the operator that operated
that right and then we get a lot of
groups and we basically want to get the
size of each and one of these
groups then we again have to trigger a
compute
I'm
sorry this now executes the group ey in
parallel we group every chunk um compute
the size and then again we pull all the
data together and do the aggregation
before we return to um our client you
can see um this one in the documentation
it's not in here that's Uber so Uber
operated by far the most right and this
one slip um which is roughly 40% of that
and the other ones are smaller ones that
I don't
know
um I added a notebook in the solutions
folder that shows potential solutions to
all of these queries if here interest
um and now we can stop for a couple of
questions there any
yes if I have a data frame that fits in
I want to do like sometimes I need to do
calculations on terms of it so I'll do
like a group ey and maybe I'll do I use
J to do the calculations on each seg
well is it going to be faster to do
something with Bas or is it going to be
about the same
or it depends how much how good your
current solution paralyzes like d split
stuff for all of your course so if you
can't do that at the moment then dask
will most certainly be faster but if
your current solution also does this
then there's probably not that big of a
differ but if your data fits into memory
it's more like using all the cores to
make your computation
FAS any other
question like anything not only to data
p
I think it's running till 12 10 is
correct I we started at 1050 so we have
still have 20 minutes left sorry for
that um then we can go through the other
examples and move over to some custom
code that you can run with d data frame
um which is maybe a related to
discuss so this is a precursor for one
of the next questions um we want to find
out the average driver
plane which is just a simple mean
computation um a mean is hard in a
distributed way because if you calculate
the mean over every chunk then you
will only get a subset of that and then
if you compute the mean over all chunks
you would have to account for the
differences in length for example so
what dusk does it it splits this
computation up into a sum which sums up
all your CHS and then a count which
counts the row and then we'll get back
um the actual mean computation um we
will be able to see this in a in a
little bit um down
here sorry that's muscle
memory let's repeat that um we have a
count here and a sum here um
again um which then is aggregated into a
mean computation
um this is one of the like things that
differentiates like single node
Computing from distributed computing
some things are just hard in a
distributed way um if you ask panas for
the median of your column this is very
easy it just looks at all the values and
then get gives you back like the median
value in
there but if you ask DK for the median
this gets significantly harder because
doesn't know how your data how your
column is ordered um the median actually
might be the smallest value in the first
ch Chun and not like the median value in
the first Chun so some things are not
part of the dask API we offer an
proximate median calculation that
approximates the median but it will
probably not be the exact value there
are some algorithms to simplify
that this is just something people have
to account for when they move from a
single node Computing to distributed
computing some things are just like more
and not this how does this handle
model approximating like
say
regression how youit like if youit it
one chunk it will give you different
answer we dis
patch
um um dask has an dusk ml that's a sub
library that ws Cy Lear but I not make
any
but the solution is like this is the Sol
problem but yeah just generally some
things you just can't do in a
distributed
environment there sometimes there is no
solution for a problem at least not a
solution that's very expensive um we can
take a brief look at something that's
very very
annoying if you want to drop all
duplicates from driver
pain it's like a float so there won't be
that many duplicat at in there
[Music]
probably um if you just do a drop
duplicates on this color this will be a
very very hard problem for last um what
we do now is like let's look at the work
level so that we can see a little bit
what's going on
here and we will first start with
dropping the duplicates for every
chunk that shouldn't have been that
f
maybe there's there aren't actually that
many rows in there let's use another
color and drop of daytime which is more
like what dusk is doing drops all
duplicates of every chunk which is fast
it's basically a pan operation but then
it will pull all the remaining values
onto one worker um which obviously is
not great as we can see here the memory
on this worker is continues to grow and
in a little bit we will reach probably
reach the red area and then this
computation is killed by D itself um
because the worker would out of memory
would run out of memory um this is one
of the problems that we are currently
working on a more efficient solution
there are more efficient ways available
but um it's just like hard doing this
efficiently um on multiple machines as
long as you don't know that as given
value is unique and what we can see here
is like task runs into red space and
then it will restart the computation
because it thinks it can do better this
happens like three or four times until
it has that what work
[Music]
out another thing that is different
between pandas and dasp like pandas data
have to fit into memory um dasp Can
spill to the dis that's attached
attached to your workers um meaning if I
go to
this that's
a what you can see here is like it's the
bottom line This popup window it's built
2 GB of data to this that is how it was
able to accomplish this computation like
pandas would have just arrowed with like
out of
memory um that said if you use the dis
that's very very slow like writing to
this is not the fastest thing you can do
compared to memory computation so it
will probably help your computations to
succeed but you will pay a hefty price
with respect to
Performance what we can see up here is
like the last aggregation of drop
duplicates took 35 seconds while all the
blockwise Dr duplic operations they are
in here they only took like 200
millisecond so the network transfer
really slowed us
down something that's generally
interesting is like uber takes a cut of
the earnings of the drivers and like
finding out how much that
is sorry um it's just something that's
pretty interesting um this will also
explain why Uber isn't making that much
money
so we use the driver p and
you divide by the column base passenger
here and then trigger a
compute like both of these operations um
don't actually do anything they just
tell us that we want to get a sum and
another sum and then we want to divide
both of them but if we remove the
compute briefly then we'll just know we
get a scaler there because two scalers
divided by each other again a scalar but
not what the actual value
is this is what compute does for
us and we can see that like uber pays
drivers around uber and Li pays drivers
around
81% um which is more than I expected to
be honest so the charge on the app isn't
that high which explains why they're
burning a lot of money
um um something else like what was I'm
like I'm from Germany
um we tip most of our cap writers um I
was a bit curious to find out if this is
true for the us as
well um we can again use the license um
the operator to group
over
first we have to Define how many rights
actually that tip you can do this
through um getting all tips that are not
equal to
zero like through assigning a new
column and then use that new column to
calculate the
mean
this is a bit more expensive because we
have multiple operations that have to
have after each other like first we
assign a new column um before we
actually do the
operation um and what we can see is like
the number here is the percentage of
what um rights were took we can see that
like it's only 15 to
20% which is like a lot lower than I
expected I don't know you feel about
that
but again up until here everything of
this is like Panda syntax and then we
just tell dusk that we want to compute
um for most of the things the switch
from pandas to dusk should be pretty um
straightforward um the last topic that I
wanted to talk about at least briefly um
pandas has things like apply or map or
or aggregate or transform where you can
execute anything you want um doing a
apply in an apply in D is a bit
different because if you apply to every
chunk then you don't have a guarantee
that you apply works as you would expect
it because um like the values you would
need for that specific function might be
in a completely different chunk and you
can't combine them so apply in general
triggers um a shuffle to realign the
values which is pretty expensive like
there's a lot of network involed
um if you don't care about that part and
just want to buy like a custom function
for every Chunk in your data frame like
some adjustment from a value to I don't
know like a logarithm a logarithm of
something like that then there is a map
partition solution right um generally
you can do help and then get the doc
spring um MTH partitions is just map my
call level to every one of my tuns um
without worrying about um combining
different Tarts
together it's a very very long do we
won't go through all of that
now if you look at this example of the
driver
P um we get
some pretty big value that's the sum of
all driver p and then we have a custom
converter here that reduces the driver
pay by a specific factor for example
0.5 or something like that this is just
a small example you could easily do this
with without map partitions
uh what my partitions now will do is
will apply my function my custom
converter to every one of our chunks or
data and then give me back a new
object so this is the initial value if
you now now apply omf partitions call
you should get back 60% of that that and
this is just like briefly to show that
me partitions works
as which should probably be
fine um you can do anything that's
arbitr that can be arbitrarily complex
with Mar partitions the only like
difference is that it won't take all
values into account there are different
solutions to achieve that but that will
be more expensive than just um doing
some random function every chunk of the
data P API is eager so it will know in
every step how your data looks like um
if you have like five columns and these
columns have like data type in 64 for
example um since DK doesn't execute
anything on the spot um it won't be
aware of that at all um it will just
know that yeah we did a a selection and
then we did a sum for example and that's
why we keep track of how the data should
look like so that we can make an
approximation what your next operation
will be for example if you have a data
frame with two columns A and B and you
select a and the next step selects B we
ideally want to fail early immediately
when you type in that statement um if
you wouldn't keep track of the number of
columns in your data frame we couldn't
do that we could just register the
column selection of Fe and like if you
workflow runs for an hour and the last
operation fails proc something like this
this is very annoying um so there's a
meta attribute that keeps track of the
shape of your data not shape the columns
and the data caps um the length is not
actually known by the
object um yeah this is
just if you play around with DK um in
map partitions for example you can
provide how the new meta object looks
like and this is helpful if a converter
is like complex and dusk won't be able
tover this for this prival example we
had here that isn't a problem because we
don't add any new columns or cast DET
something like
that so now we have like 8 minutes left
can move over to
question
dat I just wondering like why like this
gas so that are you using
p um this is something that we will fix
in 3.0 like a lot of canas operations
make deep copies of the data like Drop
is a perfect example of that um we don't
have to touch the other columns at all
but copy and use stuff in pandas is
complicated so we do a defensive copy
and just like if your data if you only
drop one of 50 colors then it will copy
the remaining 49 which is what takes up
the time I'll talk a little bit more
about two questions one I'm not using
um inter but on is that an equivalent
extension to get all these Diagnostics
that's a very very good question um this
is just built into Jupiter lab um but
there is also a website available where
you can check out do dashboard it's
listed in here
and it basically shows the same things
that you would see with the extension
and this is what you would use if you
don't use but and that's also you I get
something similar if I'm running it
locally yes okay it's exactly the same
okay the the dashboard is always the
same it just connects to different
customer it doesn't matter if this is
locally
or um the second question was since
basically move from using um band prods
MH it's that on the RO
map um making T like comp
like it might be not at the moment
um a thing that we found is that a lot
of dasp users that use DP in the cloud
are actually using not that big of
problems like they have like 16 GB of
memory available and pol doesn't doesn't
offer that many speed UPS compared to
canas if you have very small chunk like
all of our chunks in this example like
mbes
um TK has different bottom legs that
slow it um down I can like maybe show
you one real
quick I just insert a couple of cells
here and we restart our client first to
clean up all the data that are currently
in m
[Music]
so we read the
data and then we do for example a set
index set index sorts your data so in a
distributed setting a sorting is very
very expensive um let's just use a
random
color the drop of locations maybe it's
an idea it's not unique for every thing
that's maybe something that's suitable
for
this and then we can do a cist what you
will now see is like it will trigger a
lot of shuffling and network transfer so
that's what really slows us down and
just if like I don't know some is a
little bit faster wouldn't um help with
these um with these differences simply
because theor transfers but those stost
don't like we are thinking about this
but like making this St faster has a
bigger impact for most than
integrated any other
questions as we can see like the set
index that is sorting the data um there
are a lot of like Shuffle in there which
is what we use
to push data to different workers um
like this is generally if you can avoid
shs pleas
that thank you very
much